I think that Vladimir Putin and Russia
has done a huge favor to Ukraine by this
conflict I know that's very
controversial but I'm saying this
because it has built a certain national
unity that was not possible throughout
the 20 years of Ukrainian independent
existence and the Ukrainians for the
first time understand that they are they
are fighting for their identity for
their survival and they have just one
chance they can make it right or they
will disappear
my name is katana Posada Scott I'm the
director of the european academy of
diplomacy noir so it's a leadership and
diplomacy academy a lot of our
activities is focused around such themes
like as rule of law fighting corruption
human rights so how to improve our
societies
so we were signing at association
agreement with Ukraine we cannot see
this as any type of threat for the
Russian Federation because this is a
global world
the
I think what is happening in Ukraine and
the conflict that Ukraine has in Russia
is a consequence of a certain self-doubt
of Europe of a certain weakness of
Europe but we do have to remember is the
most peaceful prosperous region in the
world I think we need to understand what
we have and value it and also project
that outside
for me it was a huge surprise not only
that we put these sanctions together but
that we have been able to uphold them
which shows that we are able to it
constrain our short-term interest so the
export of our apples cheese's you know
food or big gas deals for now for
something that will we believe is bigger
more important is a common interest but
which is critical for the survival of
the EU as a project my advice to Ukraine
is that it has to declare Donbass an
occupied territory and close it down
and give the full responsibility under
the Geneva Convention to the Russian
Federation for the well-being of people
there and say we can't do anything you
know it's a huge power fighting with us
so Ukraine saying the nice guy Roman has
failed and we need to recognize this as
what for what it is an occupied
territory on our sovereign state and
continue the reforms that are going to
be painful that are going to take time
but at the end of the day will allow
Ukraine to survive as a as a state